[Music]
and welcome to Hannity and buckle up for
a big week on Thursday Florida Governor
Ronda santis will square off against
California governor Gavin Nome for what
we're calling a red state blue State
debate moderated by Yours Truly whatever
you might think about Gavin Nome you
will definitely hear a far more coherent
um individual than let's say the guy
that is living at 1600 Pennsylvania
Avenue but anyway it will be a fun
debate hope you'll join us on Thursday
night from Georgia now today a very
confused confounded Joe Biden telling
voters that the economy is doing great
Des spite of how all of us feel and what
we see every single day telling us
prices are down Americans have more
money in their pockets none of which is
true coming up we'll break down the
latest dismal economic numbers we'll
give you the truth including what is a
sharp spike in the cost of food plus
more bad polls for Joe Biden and more
Panic among the Democrats and the media
mob but first tonight breaking the
ceasefire in Gaza has now been extended
for 2 more days after 11 more hostages
were freed earlier today the fourth
hostage release so far Hamas has
returned 69 of the roughly 240 people
they kidnapped from Southern Israel in
exchange Israel has released a whopping
117 Palestinians that are actually
imprisoned including terrorists and
violent criminals one such terrorist who
was severely disfigured after detonating
a car bomb at a checkpoint was actually
given a hero's welcome upon her return
another terrorist was serving a 133-year
prison sentence for attempting to stab
Israelis during an attack conducted
alongside her cousin in contrast Hamas
Reed women young children toddlers uh
who they abducted from their homes after
murdering in many cases their parents
right in front of them dozens of women
and children were held in SPID
conditions in Gaza for 7 weeks food we
now know was limited plastic chairs were
used as beds hostages were denied the
use of bathrooms for hours on end many
of the hostages lost what is a
considerable amount of weight and some
were held in complete darkness for over
a month during their release Hamas
forced their captives to hold their
hands and they demanded they politely
wave goodbye as they were whisked away
to Freedom by the International Red
Cross now think about that how M killed
some of their parents a few weeks later
they are forcing these kids to smile
hold hands and wave goodbye to their
captors it is evil it is ugly it is
Twisted repulsive but last week one
idiotic British journalist was more
concerned that the lives of the Israeli
hostages were being valued way too much
watch this and watch the response I was
speaking to a hostage negotiator this
morning he made the comparison between
the 50 hostages hostages is that Hamas
has promised um promised to release as
opposed to the 150 prisoners that are
Palestinians that Israel has said that
it will release and he made the comp
comparison between the numbers and the
fact that does Israel not think that
Palestinian lives are valued as highly
as Israeli
lives that is an astonishing accusation
if we could release one prisoner for
every one hostage we would obviously do
that we're operating in horrific
circumstances we're not choosing to
release these prisoners who have blood
on their hands we are talking about
people who have been convicted of
stabbing and shooting attacks what a
disgusting question not surprising sadly
of course uh this was not a fair trade
for example on one side you have the
release of two what innocent
three-year-old twins from Israel on the
other you have two Palestinian ter uh
any of that seemed fair to you but in
all of his infinite wisdom your
President Joe Biden knows exactly why
Hamas took hostages and murdered what
close to 1400 innocent men women and
children on October the 7th because
according to Joe Hamas they were just
trying to disrupt Biden's achievements
in the Middle East what achievements
take a look there's an overwhelming
desire on the part of the region to let
me back up I'm I cannot prove what I'm
about to say but I believe one of the
reasons why Hamas struck when they did
was they knew that I was working very
closely with the Saudis and others in
the region to bring peace to the region
by having recognition of Israel and
Israel's right to exist all right but
here's the truth the evil ignorant
terrorists of Hamas they hate Israel
they've hated Jews they want to wipe
Israel off the map period end of
sentence they state it it is in their
Charter that's what they say that's what
they have demonstrated and because Joe
Biden freed up $50 billion for the
mullers in Iran who back Hamas and all
these other Terror groups financially
and also militarily the terrorists had
plenty of resources to carry out this
massive attack America and the world is
less and less peaceful with Biden in
charge as Former Defense secretary
Robert gas Gates famously warned Biden
always seems to make the wrong foreign
policy decis decisions he has throughout
his career and now amid rampant
anti-Semitism Biden is reportedly now
apologizing to Muslim American leaders
for questioning death toll numbers
provided by the terror group Hamas now
that is about as weak and pathetic
excuse for an American president as I've
seen in my lifetime and a guy constantly
getting bullied at home and abroad and
seems to do nothing about it for example
look at the Middle East today American
soldiers they have been attacked a
whopping 73 times since October the 17th
with little response from the
administration outside of a few targeted
Straits like at empty warehouses in
remote locations meanwhile just a few
days after meeting with Biden in
California now China's dictator
president XI once again he's ramping up
hostilities in the South China Sea
threatening a US warship in
international waters and then demanding
that the US apologize so what's Biden
going to do about that nothing no words
no actions just doing along hoping for
the best and as a result the world is a
more dangerous place hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else